it's been called a technological cold
war over the future 5g the US has been
piling pressure on the UK and other
allies not to use Chinese communications
company while way over alleged spying
risks on Monday US officials issue the
British government with a dossier of
dangers the debate risks dividing the
so-called five eyes and intelligence
alliance between the US UK Canada
Australia and New Zealand
Washington's warned it would reassess
sharing information with the UK's
intelligence services if Britain gives
Huawei the go-ahead the government will
give a final decision later in January
Prime Minister Boyce Johnson said while
ways critics need to suggest other
options if people oppose one brand or
another then they have to tell us which
is the alter what's the alternative
right on the other hand let's be let's
be clear I don't want a Z UK Prime
Minister to put in any infrastructure
that is going to prejudice our national
security there are big companies like
Nokia and Ericsson who are well
established in fairness they haven't
always kept up with the pace of speed
with Huawei in terms of the price of the
equipment the quality equipment and the
size of the equipment we also got
Samsung emerging but I think the best
solution really for the network
operators to have a mixed base of
supplies 5g isn't just about faster data
on our mobile phones
it's about immersive education it's
about self-driving cars
it's about smarter City so list goes on
if you believe the hype at all
eventually simply need 5g but it
requires a vast amount of new
infrastructure and that comes at a price
well a claims it's equipment is cheaper
than its competitors and uses less
energy giving it a potential edge in the
developing world Huawei sign 5g
contracts in more than 30 countries for
Russia to Iceland Switzerland to South
Africa the UK's proposed some
restrictions on huawei technology
Germany and France say they'll increased
cybersecurity measures several countries
are still on the fence about possible
bans be given the potential cost to
consumers the technological tussle may
be won on price rather than politics Eve
barker al jazeera London